okay thanks uh my name is Christian
gross from the University of Southern
California I'm going to be talking a
little bit about random lotteries in
redistricting Commissions in the United
States and this is really fun because in
my early career I spent a lot of time
researching
redistricting with no imp no random
component no lotteries and then a lot of
my later stuff has been on lotteries and
randomization and experiments in
legislatures and so this is kind of
bringing some of that together and uh um
I'm also kind of interested in feedback
on one particular part that I'm going to
talk about that's still in a design
phase and I'm also going to talk about
some institutional design components of
commissions across the United States
that to me are like deliberative
assemblies but that actually have policy
outcomes because they make decisions
over
mapping okay and just a little
background on what I'm going to do so
I'm going to give you some context about
what's going on in the United States
where are citizens use to draw maps for
legislative and Congressional and other
um uh Maps I'm going to then present a
research design that I'm in the middle
of and I would love feedback on that I
have no data and no results I have data
I have no results it's a natural
experiment um so their data exists but I
I don't have the results yet I would
love feedback um on that and then the
second study I'm going to talk about is
one I've done that is is two field
experiments where people were encouraged
to apply apply for Citizens reding
commissions and so we talked about this
a little bit this morning it gets at who
are the people that select into wanting
to serve in citizen assemblies wanting
to serve in citizen commissions um and
then try to encourage the types of
people who might uh engage in uptake for
those for those commissions and and then
at the end I'm going to talk a little
bit about some qualitative stuff I've
learned from doing this research from
also thinking about these questions over
time talking to people in California and
Michigan about processes that happened
there with their citizens risting
commissions um there's a little bit of
backlash to lotteries that has come up
qualitatively that I think would be
interesting to to talk about at the
end okay so a little bit of the
background um you know here's a picture
of I mean to me I think what the people
who do um Democratic deliberation in
citizen assemblies I think the
registering commissions are really nice
models because here's a picture of the
Michigan registering commission it's the
same sort of zooms that you've been
showing for Citizens assemblies right
the pictures of the commissions are
almost identical to what we're seeing
with citizens assemblies um and these
are done in a handful of locations so um
redistricting commissions redraw
typically the US House lines State
Legislative lines and then occasionally
at the local level other lines in a
small number of states um in the United
States Most states are drawn by
legislatures themselves but in some
States citizens are um are drawing the
lines and serving on commissions um it
is growing and I'll talk about a couple
examples of that um and then the thing I
think that's most important to this
conference is that the citizens
commissions to do redistricting
incorporate lotteries and they
incorporate lotteries in different ways
some of them incorporate lotteries at
the beginning of the of the process and
others incorporate it later in the
process after there's been a lot of
selection on other criteria and um and
they also serve for a fixed period of
time but unlike citizens assemblies they
serve for typically a decade right they
redraw lines and then they're around in
case there's lawsuits and they got to
come back and draw lines again so it's
actually a fairly
um it's got some fairly similar
parallels to a Citizens assembly where
citizens are brought in and they've
never really participated in any like
major government decisionmaking like by
law they're not allowed to but then they
persist for a while um if need
be all right so a little bit of
background on where does this happen
here's a map of the United States and
the four states in the light blue I want
to point out California Arizona Colorado
and Michigan all have what I would call
our independent commissions Arizona is
sort of independent and it's I think
it's in a different category but the
three sort of true citizens commissions
are California Colorado and Michigan
California started in
2010 for the for the 2010 redis process
the second one happened in 2020 um
Colorado used a Citizens commission
process in 2020 for the first time they
have separate commissions for their
Congressional lines then their State
Legislative lines both of those
commissions are random have some random
draw component to the people that end up
serving on the commissions in in
Colorado and then in Michigan also used
for the first time in 2020 and in
Michigan every s there's 13
Commissioners all of them are randomly
assigned with some um uh blocking and
waiting on party and some other
demographic characteristics so there's
three states that I think are that the
redistricting process is actually very
reflective of a deliberative um citizens
assembly style uh thing and then there's
some other Commissions in places like
Virginia New York um they're not really
citizens commissions they're they're
often appointed or they're some sort of
hybrid um appointed by people who are
elected officials so I I'm going to talk
mostly about design in California
Colorado and
Michigan all right so what what are the
policy choices that they make right and
so they deliberate like citizens
assemblies but they also make policy
choices they make pretty significant
policy choices um they're narrow policy
choices in the sense of it's a pretty
Niche area to focus on mapping and
redistricting um but basically they
create and they vote new maps for
legislative districts following the
census that's like the big policy
outcome that these these citizen
commissions do they also make compliance
choices though that have pretty big
impacts on you know cost to the states
there there's often lawsuits around
redistricting their decisions could
affect if the state gets sued or not um
for the maps that they choose they also
have to comply with the federal Voting
Rights Act they have to comply with
state level criteria and so there's a
lot of complex um material that they
have to address even though they are C
citizens who are engaged in the process
um and then they they have lots of
deliberation um they have to deliberate
over what are the communities what are
called communities of Interest which is
a term around redistricting that defines
like what is an area that people who are
citizens think is important and relevant
and so they have to go back and forth
with each other and they also take a lot
of public comment much more public
comment than is done when legislatures
draw the lines and that deliberation
both amongst themselves and then what
the public I think distinguishes the
deliberative process on the registering
commiss from how it's done um how it's
done uh
elsewhere all right just a little bit on
the quantity of
deliberation um these four bars
represent four different states only one
of them is the citizens commission
California's independent citizens
commission is listed at the top the
bottom axis is the
number of um public
hearings that were um that they held
over time um or excuse excuse me this is
hours not number that's the the hours of
public hearings that they held over the
course of 2020 through
2022 um about the redistricting in their
state you can see California has a
significant amount this is pretty
similar if you look at the other
citizens commission states too they
spend a lot of time um the other states
I picked just as you know representative
examples of a democratic jander
Republican geremander and then a
republican geremander that had some
voting rights implications New Jersey
democratic jander if you see they had
very few hours of meetings the this is
where the legislators met um or excuse
me there's a politician commission where
the legislators appoint other uh
legislators and elected officials um
Louisiana and Wisconsin had the fewest
um of these four and just in general
this is the pattern if we would look
more broadly across the states but there
is there is more deliberation among the
citizens commissions and some of that is
due to to learning and lack of expertise
they spent a lot of time hearing from
experts hearing from people um they
spent a lot of time also redoing things
that maybe legisl legislatures and and
experts might have done more quickly and
more efficiently so there's an
inefficiency that comes out of it but a
deliberative
bonus all right and then these
institutions are probably expanding in
the United States like just this week um
in Los Angeles the city council who um
and know most of you are from the East
Coast but if there's like a big racist
Tye Scandal that you may have heard
about all year ago after that the city
council voted I think Wednesday to put
on the ballot a Citizens Commission in
Los Angeles to redraw the lines in 2030
it's sort of like the states process but
but slightly different
Ohio you know this week is um trying to
put on the ballot gather signatures put
on the ballot a Citizens commission that
is actually pretty similar to the
Michigan process with a little bit of
California put in so this I think the
citizen assembly folks can learn a lot
from the redistricting commission folks
but I do think the redist commissions
have some some unique components to it
that are that are a little bit different
from the
assemblies all right so the study one
that I want to do this is a picture by
the way of um oh I forget which
commission this is of one of the redist
commissions um the but the um this is
something I haven't designed it's a
natural experiment and I'm I'd like to
just present my ideas and get feedback
from people on some measurement issues
um and also for those of you who are not
academics who are interested sort of the
institutional design for how this works
in all the different places we're going
to talk about some of that in this in
this part too um so the question here
that I'm interested in is basically does
serving and deliberative policymaking
institutions lead to Future policy
actions at the individual level not at
the aggregate level but if you are a
citizen who's randomly chosen to serve
on a citizen's registion commission do
you then in the future when your service
is complete do you engage in other
policy choices do you do you do you do
things that that um your own individual
ual you have learned through the
deliberative and citizen process how to
influence policy and then you want to
try to influence policy in other domains
later um and it's a little bit different
than the literature on deliberation
which looks at sort of what's the impact
on Civic engagement I also want to look
at that too if you're randomly chosen to
serve under a registering commission do
you also then do Civic engagement down
the road but I'm really interested in
the policy part too like once you're
once you're picked once you get that
random draw do you then decide that you
want to try to have an influence in
policy and otherwise
after you're no longer serving on the
citizens uh
commission um and so we know a little
bit about this um and we've heard about
it all day um you know but there's some
evidence that serving in citizens
deliberative bodies increases future
Civic engagement at the individual level
like if you're you know if you're on a
jury you're more likely to vote in the
future According to some studies um you
know many publics have some uh increase
in Civic engagement like Arch and fun
says that they have modest the possibly
can improve Civic engagement outcomes um
and then you know people who study
legislatures have shown that people who
serve in one institution early in their
career carry that service over in what
they've learned there into new
institutions and so I think that's
possibly the case if with citizens
commissions um and then what what I want
to do as I mentioned is sort of go
beyond this idea there's modest
improvements to Civic engagement from
Individual citizens participating in the
deliberative processes but actually that
there's policy gains that they can they
can make by serving um and so basically
at the individual level if I apply to
serve on the California redition
commission and I'm chosen randomly I'm
going to be more likely to get skills
during that two-year process or that
10-year process if the state is sued and
they have to come back that I would not
get if I were not chosen by by lot to
serve on the on the commission um and I
think some of this is individual level
where it's going to change sort of the
person person who's picked the citizen
will learn but I also think some of it
will be coming to them as well like
because they've been elevated to a
different status in terms of serving on
the citizens commission which has a
relatively High um relatively High you
know impact and relatively High um
publicity within the states that they're
done all right so it's pretty
straightforward what I'm what I'm
hypothesizing here you know if you are
basically drawn to serve on a
redistricting commission where you've
made policy choices in the past in the
future you're going to try to engage in
more policy action um where I would like
help is how do I measure that policy
action um and then if you're also drawn
you're going to probably engage in
future Civic engagement um as we would
expect in the literature on deliberation
and so here are the UN of analysis is
not the commission but each individual
person who applies to
serve all right and so the measurement
that I'm interested in here is um the
future policy action and it's it's sort
of tricky what the policy action might
might actually be um and then I'm also
interested in future Civic engagement
and I might do a survey with people
who've applied and people who have
served under registering commissions who
were who are randomly chosen or not but
I'm not sure about that um and basically
what I'm going to do is compare the
applicants who are randomly assigned to
serve on a commission to those that were
not and then look at these policy
outcomes and so I'm looking for ideas
for some of these outcome measures that
we could talk about all right a couple
ideas I have already is just um you know
engaging in policy more broadly in the
community writing op EDS writing um you
know writing about public policy Andor
Civic engagement um once you've served
so you know if you're picked to do this
you then might want to go and write
about what Fair processes would be what
would be better deliberative processes
in other domains how you work with other
people your ideas about redistricting 10
years later right um maybe even going to
Ohio to campaign on behalf of their
ballot initiative if you've served in
Michigan and things like that if you're
picked to be on it versus those that
were not it's harder to measure this you
know I'm going to try to measure this
via just straightforward Google searches
of news and op EDS and then also like
maybe Lexus Nexus and this would be the
applicants who who were randomly picked
and the applicants that were not
randomly picked um the other one that I
think would be a little bit harder to
measure but I would like to because I
think it's it's very likely is are they
participating in public forums and
panels right and so these are these are
people that once they've served in these
commissions they're going to try to do
more in the future and that's something
else that I want to try to
measure um one other one that I want to
measure is um what do they do afterwards
right so I think that serving on these
citizens commissions will increase their
Public Service motivation so they I'd
like to look at their career changes and
this is a relatively small group of
people who end up applying for reding
commissions and then either randomly
being picked or not the people who are
picked to serve do they go into
nonprofit do they go into advocacy do
they leave the private sector or do they
stay stay in the positions that they
were in previously and my hypothesis
would be that once they've served in the
citizen commission they may look towards
government advocacy nonprofit more than
the private sector having had an
impact commiss starts no I'm going to
get to that in about two slides yeah
that's that and I would also like your
help there yeah
okay and then a couple other things that
I can't do but I want to mention it
because people have suggested this so
behavioral outcomes we often use to
measure Civic engagement is voting you
know serving running for office um
donating to candidates right all of
these things are prohibit well voting is
not a Prohibition donating to candidates
and um running for office is often
prohibited if you uh agree to serve on
these commissions and it's also a
precondition of applying and and being
uh able to serve alt together um and
then these are also High these are these
are people that are sort of high Civic
engaged already by choosing to apply
right and so they're people who are
turning out to vote in some States
they're required to have voted and had a
history of voting in the past so these
are kind of typical Behavior outcomes we
would study in political science but we
can't do that here so that's why I'm
looking at some of these more creative
policy action and Civic engagement
outcomes so the other the other thing
that's a challenge that I want to talk
about is the regist commissions have
small numbers the Commissioners
deliberating and their processes are
different for how they're selected there
is a there is a randomization and the
lottery in all of these cases that I've
talked about at in the three US states
and also I'm in some localities that I'm
going to talk about but there there's a
small number of people and then also
those rules vary slightly all right so
here's an example in California I just
want to run through how it works and so
this is you know what's the
randomization that's going on in in
these uh districts and also this is the
state level and um most of the local
redistri Commissions in California at
the county and the city level also work
very similarly to this um this is a
picture of all the people who were who
served um one of them is my former PhD
student which I'm very proud of that she
was randomly drawn to serve on the read
hising commission um and she's a
professor at Pomona College um but uh
the selection process is actually pretty
elaborate so in 2020 there are about
20,000 people who applied but didn't
complete the applications right so they
had to get reference letters they had to
explain why they want to do it and they
didn't they didn't write saay right like
the the usual stuff like that they just
filled out their name and so the reality
of who applied there are 200 2003 people
who actually applied for the Commission
in the state of California it's a
relatively small number if you think
about how large the state is but it's
also a lot of people um in terms of raw
numbers all right then what happens
after that the state Bureau of audits
and this is in the state law um the
state Bureau of audits Narrows the pool
to 60 finalist right and so there's not
a random selection at this point from
going to from 2003 to 60 the state
Bureau of audits there's a little bit of
randomization in the auditor stage for
which Auditors get chosen to actually
review the applications so they Auditors
that are drawn and block randomized
based on their party registration to
review the applications and move them
down to 60 um but they evaluate quality
who are these people are they people
that have some expertise are they people
that can work together there's different
criteria that they have to they have to
use um this is the state auditor drawing
the random part later um and then the
legislature non-randomly also reduces
the pool of applicants to 36 so this is
where the party leaders of each of of
each party say I don't like this person
or this person's a you know secret
Democrat or a secret Republican and they
eliminate people non-randomly um and
then after that you get down to
36 relatively small sample and then
eight Commissioners are randomly chosen
from the 36 using block randomization by
parties you got three Rs three d's and
two people who are um
other part of your Independence and um
and they they literally do pull bingo
balls or I mean um ping pong balls or
Bingo numbers out of a out of a hat or
out of a
thing um so what I'm going to do is use
this and pull data across the states
with the commissions um but we're
talking about some small numbers right
and then look at these outcomes that I
that I mentioned so the treatment is
like where you randomly picked and then
of that 36 at the very end the control
group would be the people that weren't
picked
randomly okay and so here's how it's
done in these in these three states but
four commissions um so California
already talked about there are eight
Commissioners
selected and then there's there's 22
finalists not selected and the reason
there's 22 is that six people are
actually chosen by the eight people who
are randomly picked and so there's 22
control group eight who were randomly
selected to choose Michigan has a very
different process than California's
everyone who
applies is put into a random draw and
the lottery happens there without any
sort of criteria to try to move people
out for expertise or or so on there's no
quality control per se they just have to
apply and then they're randomly drawn
there is some waiting um on gender
region um and uh other criteria I don't
know exactly how that was done there a
private auditing firm was hired to do it
in 2020 I'm trying to find out more
about that um and then they also block
randomize on party um and so there's 13
treatment people randomly in the
citizens commission 147 finalists in
Michigan that were not selected um
Colorado has different commissions for
the Congressional State Legislative
level but again six people are randomly
chosen then 144 finalists are not
selected um and in Colorado they also
have some appointees of um uh
politicians who serve with them but
there's no random component of that so
I'm only focusing on the citizens part
so in total if you pull across all four
of these commissions you got 33 people
chosen by lot 456 finalists not chosen
by lot um and then this is where I would
leverage the control versus the
treatment for the policy outcomes or the
Civic engagement outcomes in the future
one other much larger table so just
direct your eyes to LA County Santa
Barbara San Diego um there are also very
similar ones at the local level that I
would like to look at in California
they're expand a lot too um and here
it's very similar to what I talked about
in California but there's we're starting
to get to where we have a little bit
more there's 54 people chosen by lot
across these localities LA County um and
San Diego County I was a I also not only
am I interested in this as a professor
and researcher I also was a consultant
for San Diego County's redistricting
process um and so they used a commission
for the first time in 2020 where eight
people were um randomly Chosen and then
50 final is not selected but this this
is basically how these institutions are
designed for those who are interested in
that from translating over to Citizens
assemblies um but then also I think it
creates some real leverage that I want
to look at in terms of the political
science outcomes my concern is of course
these are different institutions with
somewhat different designs even though
there's randomization really small n
right and so I can pull this and look at
it but then you know I'm interested in
what feedback you have besides the the
same too small to bother um that I could
still try to leverage this okay um and
then I want to talk a little bit about a
second set of studies that I've done
already that might help you to figure
out who are these people like who wants
to serve on a redistricting citizens
commission who who wants to serve in a
who wants to go to a Citizens assembly
right who who decides to apply for
something like this because you can't be
an elected official you can't run for
office in the future right you have to
be interested in politics and want to
make a difference but you have never
displayed any other Behavior suggesting
you want to do that in your life so um
and you there's prohibitions on donating
to candidates and things like that so
it's a really it's a really interesting
group of people and trying to figure out
who these people are all right and so
this study is based on two field
experiments that I did in the 2020
process in California in Los Angeles
County that um basically examined uptake
and participation like who who applies
and can we encourage more people to
apply and see who those people
are all right and so the argument here
is just basically people who are
publicly service motivated or who have
Financial incentives may be willing to
serve right and so the experiment is
going to test those two different
questions do you do you want to serve on
a registering citizens Commission
because you find out that you might get
paid and it's an additional like because
there is limited pay on all of these you
the financial incentive May spur you to
participate or do you want to do it out
of public service if you give them a
sort of this will help this is like a
Civic classic Civic engagement message
that you might do with a gov style
experiment will they serve all right and
then the punchline with this I won't go
into all of the results but the
punchline is the public service
motivation encouraged people to sign up
and apply um the financial incentive did
not the financial incentive had no
impact also tested Financial um
Financial incentive meaning just telling
them how much they will be paid if they
are chosen not any additional incentive
um the public service message mixed with
the financial message also made no
difference in terms of the it's it was
similar to the public service um
effect all right and so what the two
experiments were um one I partnered with
a good government organization who was
concerned about the number of people who
would apply for the California
registering commission and um we
embedded this encouragement experiment
with uh with them we invited academic
experts um primarily social science
professors at University of California
institutions and a handful of other uh
private institutions um in Cal in in the
state and it was fielded in summer of
2019 told them about the process gave
them the application and gave them those
different messages I did a parallel
experiment for the Los Angeles County
Commission only that was also in
partnership with a good government
organization based in La a different
group um that was encouraging
Asian-American and Latino members of
their good government organization to
apply and the exact same experiment was
done
there that's okay and the outcome
variable here is really straightforward
did the person apply or
not the as I mention there's a control
group of people who didn't receive any
message at all from the nonpartisan
organizations there's one that got the
public service motivation message the
financial message and the one that got
the two
together this is the public service
message down here in the Square
Commissioners who apply and are selected
should be driven by a motivation toward
Public Service in order to make
California a better place and shape the
state's future this text is pretty
similar to the messaging that the state
was using itself to get people to serve
it also included a brief description
deadline links to the application and
all of that
stuff same message with the links and
the the details and and how you apply
was given to a different group that was
randomized um and this just said what
the what the amount you would get paid
if you served it's actually not very
high for the number of hours if you
remember that figure I show at the
beginning with the total number of hour
but it's not it's not nothing either
it's actually substantial in terms of um
if you think about like U um the median
income of California right um and so
this is just saying how much you might
get paid and what the people were paid
in the previous the previous one um and
this is per dium by the way this isn't a
salary but this is you know there's a
little bit of a financials this is also
true right so this is actually like
factual
information and then both
messages and so the results I I
mentioned Financial incentive had no
impact at all but the public service
message PSM people were 1.4 percentage
points more likely to apply to serve on
the citizens commission um than the
control group and then the you know the
other conditions just didn't just didn't
make a difference and that was the case
in the Statewide experiment and also the
case in the Los Angeles experiment with
a different sample of
people
many
oh yeah so it depends like in the year
in which they're redistricting it's
probably 8 to 10 hour meetings about
twice a week um sometimes longer like at
the very end when they're almost done
like in November and December of 2021 it
was
probably 10 hour meetings almost every
day like Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday
and then they're done and then once like
in the case of California they completed
the maps I think on December 23rd and um
the then there was very little then they
went to Sacramento and they delivered
the maps and then there's not much left
to do I think they had a party um and
then there was basically meetings every
month or two right and that's more of
like what did they learn kind of coming
together occasionally and now they
hardly ever made it all right but they
do they do stand for a decade in case
there's a need to come back like in case
one of the maps gets a lawsuit so like
in Michigan right now there is a lawsuit
against the map that's in court and if
that succeeds they will have to come
back again and do
10 hour days three days a week for
probably about a month or so yeah so
it's a very high intensity commitment
for a short period of time and but it's
a little bit like the deliberative
assemblies that go on for quite a long
time where you bring people
back did you look at herous treatment
effects you assume that like the Bas
income that's under the midpoint of your
financial treatment would be positively
incentivized while above it would be in
that with net app right no that's a
great idea and I have and because most
of the sample for the Statewide study
study are public employees because
they're professors at um public
universities the data on their income is
available so I can do that but I haven't
yeah
yeah yeah all right so you know
concluding um a couple things I want to
talk about like what have I learned from
some of this and also what have I
learned from I'm observing right if
you're interested in randomization and
commissions if you're in citizens
assemblies and deliberation what can we
learn from Michigan California Colorado
these localities so few things um you
know qualitatively there has a there
have actually been some concerns raised
by Advocates um and by Advocates I mean
people who were on the ground um good
government groups uh or advocates in the
sense of um groups who were interested
in you know increasing diversity in the
redistricting process who were concerned
about voting rights um in general
they've been considered very positive by
the way so in general the commission
processes have been rated highly by
Advocates compared to when legislatur
draw the lines um but within that the
discussion around randomization has been
um I think a little misguided in the
policy community in some of the states
and so just for example um in California
there's um if you recall it was a really
racially and gendered and um disability
diverse group of people who were
selected to serve um however in the
first draw of the eight people who are
randomly chosen in California um it was
very diverse in terms of Asian-American
black and white but there were no Latino
members who were chosen to to serve
through the random draw and that's just
small sample part of it is the number of
people who applied and sort of
differential in people who applied but
part of it was just the small sample you
occasionally get these outcomes that are
not demographically represented when
you're only randomly drawing eight
people right and so there's a huge this
is like a huge problem in a state like
California where the nearly 40% of the
population is Latino um and then the
next six who are chosen nearly all of
them were Latino which created
demographic balance um but because that
happened because of just that
statistical Quirk of the you know small
sample and randomization a lot of you
know Latino advocacy groups have
expressed concern about randomization
right because of that one observed
outcome even though of course
randomization you know assuming it was
done fairly is fair right and so that's
something that is a thing that just
whenever you're dealing with
randomization in deliberative groups and
it's a small sample and there may be a
lack of demographic diversity that
coincidentally happens it's going to
raise a lot of fairness issues um in
Michigan I talked to some people there
who were concerned about randomization
from a quality standpoint so because
Michigan has no vetting about who
applies um that you just apply and then
they pick people there are some concerns
raised that some Commissioners had were
higher quality than others and unlike a
deliberative assembly there's no real
time to learn I mean there is time to
learn but you really have to start
making policy choices by serving as
opposed to kind of getting up to speed
um couple things that are important in
all of these states is staff and so I
think this is relevant for deliberative
assemblies and any other kind of
citizens assembly that you want to think
about they all hire staff and it's their
choice of Staff of who they hire but
that staff can really be important the
same way that there's a bureaucracy for
an elected legislature that you know the
um legislators will put in uh that are
semi-permanent in the case of these
commissions and so like the having the
experts that they can hire can be
important but then the ultimate
principal or these citizens who are
effectively making the the decisions um
also in Michigan the Secretary of
State I thought wisely and interesting
from a social science standpoint and she
is a former Professor um she randomly
sent invitations to all um miss or a
subset of people in Michigan to
encourage them to apply trying to get my
hands on those data um and those those
those letters have also received some
negative feedback because some people
thought that the government was
requiring them to apply some people
applied and then actually made it to the
next stage and were like I don't know
what's going on I don't want to do this
so there's a little bit of things when
you're incorporating lotteries into
public decision- making you know how
whatever happens in one or two anecdotes
will actually inform the views of how
people respond to them so just think
about that for those of you thinking
about randomization and and Democratic
uh deliber
um and this is what I mentioned there's
some there are some there's some
emerging push back on some of this but
also I think I think positively there
are a lot of group good government
groups pushing these reforms like the
Ohio proposal um for the commission has
this they they have lotteries embedded
within it um because it's uh it it does
actually
increase um fairness right but then
there are Equity concerns about who
applies right and so if you have an
unrepresentative set of applications
then the outcome may not appear
Equitable or is not
Equitable okay that's all I've got um
I'm happy to take questions but it's
just been really fun I appreciate Ally
thank you for organizing this because
these that study to is a paper I've been
meaning to work on and this caused me to
get going on it and then this conference
has made me think a lot about ways of
incorporating redition commissions
Democratic deliberation and um uh
citizen
assemblies
[Applause]
um hi Mark Orton um so I guess I have
two questions the first is can you think
of other examples of similar sorts of
bodies to redist redistricting
commissions that have similar properties
that are other examples in our society
where these things are used do you mean
like having citizens in general or like
the randomization component combined
with some sort of other selection
process guess it's you know similar
bodies relate it's like a kind of
independent citizens body doing a
specific task in the context of the
government I
guess no off the top of my head I cannot
though I'm sure they exist but I think
my head is so in the redistricting
commissions right now that I'm not
thinking about it so let me get back to
you on that okay and then the second
question is you mentioned in Michigan
there were concerns about the the
quality of the people because it was
just pure random you what was the EXP
experience of how that commission
functioned yes so I mean I actually
think it worked out pretty well I think
on balance the commission did well I do
think there were some people who
participated more heavily and so what
what ends up happening is if you have
the true randomization as your selection
process it probably privileges a few
more of the people that just were
randomly chosen who
were the more active participants right
and there there are a couple people who
didn't attend as frequently that
happened with one person in California
as well um I also think some of the
criticism in Michigan is is coming from
people with interest in the outcome of
the maps and so um I I I mention that
not because I think the criticism is
correct as much as it's something that
was discussed and came up during the
process like who are these people why
why is this person not attending every
meeting right so any any way that you
can sort of kind of attack if you you
know if you're the legislature and you
would like to keep the map or you have
your own your own interest that and
you're not Drawing the Line so some of
it is that strategy but I also think
some of it is some of the people applied
and they you know they weren't really
sure what they wanted to do um and if
they wanted to do it and so there's also
a lot of drop off like so people
initially applied and then once they
kind of found out what it was really
about they didn't they didn't move on to
the next stage but in in California and
other places where the
selection that's not random weeds out
people who maybe are less interested
early that's less of a
problem
but was there any empirical evidence
that any groups were attempting to co-op
the the citizens assembly or feed them
information or um you know make promises
to them or anything like that or or did
that was that control well controlled so
there was an Evidence of the latter as
far as as I know um in any of the states
but I do think that um and I think this
is interesting if we think about citizen
assemblies broadly like so the re
commissions are very transparent by law
in all three of these states and they
have to be and as a result you know
people with interest in the maps know
who the Commissioners are um and they
have very strict laws on Communications
and what they're allowed to do but it
the public comments can become um
effectively public lobbying about what
other people want so I think that your
first part of of the question you know
there's evidence from the first um the
first uh California experience in
2010 that you know people were were
putting forward ideas um in
2020 the mayor of San Jose called the
commission several times and AR talked
about how San Jose is a community that
must be together um because I think he
wanted to run for Congress right and so
that that's actually a pretty um and and
they didn't end up following what he
suggested either which is but there's
there is a way to influence these
citizens but it all has to happen in a
public meeting and so to me that is a
little bit more um even though
potentially normatively concerning the
empirical evidence would say we all can
observe that as opposed to and you know
if a legislature is Drawing the Line in
Wisconsin we can't observe what what is
happening and who's lobbying whom about
that so I think yeah but I think there's
some empirical evidence of that um on
the other hand the negative feedback in
multiple States all three states
actually haven't talked about Colorado
from some um some of the parties and
some specific elected officials would
suggest that there may be less empirical
evidence of that because the negative
feedback came after the maps were done
yeah hi Philip Lindsay from the
Democracy Innovation Hub at Bard College
um two questions the first one is so
many times I think because we don't
really train facilitators in our society
at large we don't think about the
facilitators they're blind they're
they're they're not included I'm curious
if there were facilitators in these
processes or and and how that played
into you know how much time what people
were speaking and um and then the second
question is I always imagine that if if
you get randomly selected citizens you
you bring them together and say hey you
should you're going to redraw the maps
there's there's all this gerrymandering
that at some point some citizens would
propose some other form of proportional
representation for their state and I'm
wondering if that conversation ever came
up or is there just is it just so so
unconstitutional at the state level or
there's so many hurdles that like the
conversation never would never go near
that yeah it's a really that's a really
good point um so I mean on the first
one the you know very slightly but on
balance there's not what I would call
facilitators like so they're on there
they serve they do hire an executive
director they hire legal staff right
there's there's there are staff who help
guide them in specific things but um
typically they're leading the meetings
and so what happened what California did
was they rotated the chair of their
committee they just chose to do that
early on and then that person was
effectively the facilitator for the
other 13 Commissioners during the
meetings um there are um you know
there's some there because this the all
of these three states and then if it
passes in Ohio and the localities
there's some pretty strict rules in the
law about what they can talk about when
it has to get done deadlines for
completion that I wouldn't call that
facil facilitation as much as they had
to have public comment they had to be in
deliberation with each other and then
they had to be in deliberation with the
public or at least they had to hear the
public they didn't necessarily have to
respond and then that would repeat again
and again and so because of that the
deliberation almost happened because
they were required by law even without a
facilitator but certainly the chair
ended up facilitating a lot and you
could see the the commissioner who was
the chair with often step back and not
speak as much um while the other 13 were
were talking um there are also some
people who are more like they're they're
just the leaders that emerg through the
process and were a little more dominant
in the process towards guiding things
and and undoing things and um um in all
of the different states uh Colorado
Michigan and and California but on your
second question is like does this make
them want to just do electoral system
change that's a really good idea and
that's kind of what I want to get out
the policy action so they can't do that
they can't in the commission say we want
to get rid of single member districts
this is frustrating there they're Bound
by they're Bound by the law but some of
I anecdotally I do know some of the
Commissioners who served in 2020 have
already attended conferences about
election system change proportional
representation multi-member districts um
you know this this sort of did um kind
of consistent with my hypothesis and
it's I think I'm going to measure that
outcome specifically some of them are
now working on the sort of election
systems broad policy changes that they
they may like to see or at least want to
be part of the
conversation
thanks so much yeah um so uh Kevin
Elliot from here at Yale um yeah so just
on this last Point um so when you were
trying to differentiate Civic engagement
from policy actions I was a little
puzzled at first and then you when you
began talking about it uh it became
clearer because I thought about it in
terms of the policy actions that you're
talking about are things that are
specifically related to redistricting it
seems like in other words they've
acquired policy expertise issue
expertise on that uh which then uh it
seems like you're your all of the
suggested measures had to do
specifically with their deployment of
this specific issue expertise that they
had um and and when you think about that
as opposed to more General Civic
engagement right that that makes sense
to me as a as a distinction right so it'
be Civic engagement on the thing that
they are now relative experts on as
opposed to Civic engagement more broadly
yeah that's that's a good point I mean I
was thinking of Civic engagement more
more in kind of the traditional
literature of like how we've measured it
and then the policy part separately I do
think that the policy actions that you
would expect coming out of service and
being randomly drawn would be on the I'd
say like the broader election system
topics it may not be about redistricting
precisely but could be um however again
I have anecdotal evidence and I've not
collected the data yet um that some of
them have done other other public policy
style things po Post Service like some
of the people served on the 2020 excuse
me the 2010 California commission who
are now done who are randomly drawn you
know they're on they're on panels about
what can California teach Arizona right
and it's not about redistricting it's
about sort of just having policy
discussions and and things of that
nature um some of this is also it's like
you have to figure out what's the supply
versus the Demand right like how much of
this is the individual level person
serves and now they want to go and
engage in policy um in other domains or
is this people are now seeking them out
because they they W you know they
watched them for a year do deliberative
meetings with other citizens um and
that's harder for me to tease out but I
do think this translates Beyond just
redistricting I think it translates to
policy action broadly with the
limitations of you can't run for office
for I think in all the states for almost
a decade or more you're limited to do
like straightforward political
activities it is experience I yeah oh
yeah still that's a good point yeah so
they they they actually have much more
experience that they've gained via
skills that they wouldn't have had
before they served yeah yeah okay great
thank
[Applause]
you